I'm Nina and I'm a fashion designer just
disappears when it gets wet there were
two models I think standing under a sort
of shower roof and I just the water
would come out it would slowly like just
disappear and it's so magic that it's
the most impractical thing ever when it
rains usually they have the collections
that are very arty and then they have
another collection that is more wearable
and that's the commercial part of the
design and what they show is the more
like it's just not exciting to be like
oh it's a new socks yeah no not really
if Prada is putting like socks with high
heels next season you will see everybody
wearing at Fashion Week's with the high
heels which is something we always
thought probably you know growing up in
Venice when you're a kid you have a lot
of freedom here parents not worried that
the car will just the worst thing can
happen to you is that you fall in a
canal and that happens pretty you know
really often but people just would jump
and say you know they don't like the
kick-drum neck doesn't happen sometimes
you know people are with the trolley
with a little kitten and the truck leg
they you move for a second they turn
around to throw away the trash and it's
you know and everybody's like oh my gosh
you know and it happened and people just
stop and they think they're kids I'm
sure that people that grew up in cities
like Venice with so much art they just
have like a natural instinct to beauty
somehow it's the same for when it comes
to fashion fashion it's really like one
of the ways you express beauty so if
you're looking for beauty in things how
are you coping there living in Berlin
it's really hard Chris I challenge you
to rap about
onomatopoeia splash boom yeah yeah those
kind of words yeah about Pindaric flight
and about what indirect flight when you
start with the topic and with a complete
different one topically
to another one and then to another one
you're talking about civil war and you
end up talking about chocolate and the
third word hmm I'm not sure about how to
say it if it isn't iridescent yeah
lovely onomatopoeia Pindaric flight and
iridescent yeah thank you
year making money cash robbing let me
get this a - and a smash ride in got the
woods with the ash leave it all burnt
onomatopoeia sound it's a thing we
learnt when we're at school see it on
the chalkboard get the word I know it is
that's the reward get the chalk sound
when the nail scrape down
onomatopoeia is on the ground let me
tell you something you give me such a
thrill I feel it onomatopoeia come the
window sill window sill sounds like what
it means I don't even know linguist
people as I've seen they be like no it's
not the true definition but that put
them in a punch in position and swung
compassion like my name's Batman you
know in the cartoons when the stars go
slam all of those words they fit right
in I'm gonna get Bing gonna get
flattened am i alight here because it
takes my ear
gotta get pandering right up here pan
Derek like I'm totally indirect I can't
get two subjects go indirect Lee I just
need pop like I'm riding buses if you
want direct speech dead good be fusses
you'll be like angry when I digress I
think about words and then i undress why
am i getting naked when i say this it's
where it's a route convoluted take this
from one to the other the pass through
the numbers is so cool a flow like the
river called the hung but you don't have
those hits in the northeast England
you got canals in Venice so you don't
understand less than ya like the moon
got a crescent feathers on a pheasant
shine bright iridescent that means
something gotta gaze and it sparkles I
see it and I'm like whoa everybody har
call you and gather round hoc on a
matter tag - I see the color shine red
white and blue they're the colors you
know what I mean it's iridescent on the
flag white red and green is so clean
when it sparkles shine like a diamond
strain little spherical light
you should buy one maybe made with glass
or plastic I don't know the interior is
so elastic
Thank You flight that is a really hard
one hurt good I really enjoyed wrapping
for you